[Musique]
entrée au musée de la bible à washington
c'est pénétrer dans une cathédrale où
l'on découvre l'histoire et l'impact du
livre le plus lu et le plus vendu au
monde sur quatre étages d'une
architecture spectaculaire les visiteurs
traversent des espaces d'exposition
feutrée qui inspire paix et sérénité
les bibles sur lesquels les présidents
américains ont prêté serment à celle de
martin luther king en passant par la
bible d'elvis presley
le livre saint est présenté sous toutes
ses formes
construit au coût de 500 millions de
dollars
le musée a été financée par la famille
green de l'oklahoma
les milliardaires évangélique qui ont
fait fortune dans le commerce de détail
c'est quoi
en marchant on découvre l'influencent de
la bible dans les prisons dans la mode
et même à l'hôtel dieu de québec un
modèle écrit tant de compassion biblique
on a voulu dépoussiérer ce livre vieux
de plus de 2000 ans une diversité qui
ravit les visiteurs allaient notre mais
le musée fait quand même une place à
certains détracteurs des écrits de la
bible de grands scientifiques comme
galilée au xvième siècle qui ont osé
interpréter la bible et qui ont été
persécutés par l'église
aujourd'hui certains savants chante les
louanges de la bible dont les écrits
distille les inspire
l'expérience est aussi multimédia
partout des projections et des effets
visuels nous plonge au coeur de
l'histoire de la bible qui inclut
l'ancien et le nouveau testament
[Musique]
ici une marche dans nazareth
le musée de la bible a été pensé pour
satisfaire croyants et non croyants
on ne cherche pas à convertir à défaut
d'y trouver la fois les ati découvriront
un lieu de recueillement et de savoir
pour les convertis le musée de la bible
les aura conforté sur l'importance des
écritures saintes dans l'histoire du
monde ici christian latreille
radio-canada washington
[Musique]